ustedes los atletas cómo se sienten con
esta noticia y los rumores en torno a
estos juegos no les recuerdo un poco a
la sensación que tuvieron el año pasado
buenas noches sin literal fue como la
misma sensación una incertidumbre
gigante no sabíamos que era cierto que
no era cierto o incluso nos levantábamos
buscando noticias a ver si había salido
algún comunicado oficial y pues
obviamente la incertidumbre porque
llevamos cuatro años preparándonos más
uno más que tenemos de cuenta de la
pandemia que salgan pues como estos
rumores afectan muchísimo ahora se
oponía pasó lo que pasó ustedes van a
seguir entrenando situaciones como éstas
no los desmotivan a lo mejor a ustedes
que son los protagonistas de los
olímpicos
bueno habló personalmente a mí y me
desmotiva obviamente ayer incluso cuando
vi esa noticia me desmotiva mucho pero
oí que no teníamos a las 6 de la mañana
que fue nuestro estreno el comunicado
oficial incluso seguimos entrenando
porque sabemos cuál es nuestra meta y no
podemos parar porque es una carrera
contra el tiempo ahorita nosotros
tenemos del clasificatorio y pues
obviamente nuestra meta es poder asistir
a los juegos olímpicos así de pronto
sean diferentes pero será algo por lo
que hemos estado trabajando tantos años
así es y si estos se cancelan supongamos
es escenario estaría dispuesto a iniciar
otro ciclo para prepararse para los
próximos
digamos que en mi caso en estos momentos
es una decisión muy difícil pienso que
él no me seguiría preparando para otro
ciclo olímpico otros cuatro años como
dueto
ahorita mis metas digamos están poder
prepararme mejor profesionalmente
quiero aprender otras cosas entonces en
cuatro años en la adaptación artística
como lo esto implicaría dedicarle
muchísimo más tiempo que podría de
pronto dedicarle a otros sueños y metas
que quiero cumplir desde este año
estefanía también le quiero preguntar se
han tenido una comunicación oficial del
comité olímpico colombiano
bueno la verdad hoy hemos tenido la
comunicación el comunicado oficial que
salió del comité olímpico colombiano
incluso palabras del presidente en donde
ratificó pues que el comunicado que
salió ayer había sido falso que los
juegos olímpicos siguen en pie que eso
nos da un poquito más de tranquilidad un
poquito más de ánimo para seguirnos
preparando porque personalmente el día
de ayer sí y me afectó bastante con
todos estos rumores ahora que le dice
qué mensaje le da a sus compañeros
atletas
bueno yo creo que nos falta muy poquito
muy poquito para poder de quitarnos de
todo el trabajo que hemos hecho durante
tantos años es toda una carrera a la que
nosotros llevamos trabajando entonces a
no rendirnos de que pueden haber muchos
comentarios pero el mensaje es a seguir
adelante hasta el final y luchar la con
todas